you know it's hard to believe i think
we're still kind of grappling with this
holiday travel isn't that far away
thanksgiving just six weeks from now
like i feel like we should be planning
our menu already we're talking about
travel here if you're still planning a
trip
it is not too late to score a deal so
that is good news but experts say there
are a few things that you do need to
know before you book a flight so our
hector mejia is joining us live outside
mccarran airport with those important
details hi hector
hey there good morning heather and john
with the major flight cancellations we
saw here and around the country by
southwest airlines many are wondering if
that's just a preview of what travelers
will have to deal with once the holiday
season kicks in also with the pandemic
still going on nearly all major u.s
airlines are requiring the covid vaccine
for employees cbs news reports the union
representing american airlines warns
staffing shortages could hit this
holiday travel season if employees lose
their jobs for refusing to get the
coveted shot the largest pilots
association and most major airlines
though confirmed to cbs they will follow
president joe biden's executive order
requiring workers to get vaccinated for
example united airlines was the first of
at least six carriers to implement the
vaccine mandate and as of last week
about 200 of their employees were still
left unvaccinated so travel experts are
talking about when's the best time to
make your to book your flights for
christmas well in case you're wondering
the cutoff date is october 31st if you
still have to plan and book your
christmas day flight reporting live
outside mccarran airport hector mejia
live local now time is ticking plan
ahead factor plan ahead that is the
trick thank you sir appreciate it
640 hey speaking of the hall